this christmas it's not just santa that
two-year-old edward is waiting for
concerned about the environment his
grandparents have opted for a different
type of christmas tree delivered in
december picked up again in january and
then replanted the family hope their
rented christmas tree will be more
friendly for the environment
because i see the same tree year on year
and i can watch it grow and when edward
comes in it'll get bigger
and edward will get bigger and it's just
it'll be just like bringing part of the
family for chaos ways really to
something that has some meaning and it
can you know environmentally friendly is
great because we know we're not throwing
anything away
eco elf is the brainchild of calamo
driscoll i was just fed up for throwing
away christmas trees me and my wife
we've always loved getting a real tree
even from when i was a child you know
and the smells great
but taking it down to the council
organized tiff in the car park around
the corner and seeing a massive pile of
cut trees is just a shame really each
christmas up to eight million real trees
are sold in the uk
there is of course no shortage of
artificial options
for many they are the centerpiece of
christmas but as we're all more
conscious of our carbon footprint just
which are better for the environment
real or fake
according to the carbon trust a six and
a half foot artificial tree equates to
around 40 kilograms of co2 when
considering manufacturing metal plastic
packaging and transport
a real fertilized tree is a tenth of
that at around four kilograms of co2
however certain types of artificial
trees can have a lower overall carbon
footprint if used for at least seven
years
although artificial might be better long
term a real tree can have other
environmental benefits
if your tree at its end of life if it's
collected by a local authority and then
you know um burnt for energy or or used
um as wood chipping or as composting
then those have really positive benefits
as well so in the composting or chipping
example obviously it helps with you know
soil quality improvements and that's
really important real or fake it remains
a divisive issue it looks to have a real
tree together it seems a bit lazy to
have um artificial one how long have you
had your fake tree
oh
it's about 30 to 35 years old has it
still got some needles it's yes it has
so we've got needles still got the
fairy on the top
dan whitehead sky news